you're watching Al Jazeera and let me
bring you some breaking news now
Israel's military says two Israelis have
died in a shooting in the occupied West
Bank it's happened in the Palestinian
Village of khwara just south of Nablus
we're going to bring in Nida Ibrahim
who's joining us now from Bethlehem what
more do we know Nida
well you know that the Israeli Army
treating this
is
suspected attack that's why they've
closed the area near the huwara town
where there has been an intensified
military presence for over a year now in
the area because of increasing shooting
attacks by Palestinians against Israeli
settlers who are usually in the area now
we've had reports in the beginning that
were conflicting some were saying maybe
this was a fight maybe this was a
criminal thing now we know from the
Israeli forces and the Israeli Army that
they're treating this as a suspected
attack by Palestinians let's not forget
that what a husband a flash point of a
lot of tension we've seen a few months
ago Israeli settlers rampaging through
hawara during the night burning
Palestinian homes and we've seen also
Palestinian attacks against Israeli
forces so far as forces and settlers so
far since the beginning of this year
we're talking about more than 33
Israelis who were killed in Palestinian
attacks most of those are either
soldiers or settlers but we're talking
about more than
224 Palestinians who were killed by
Israeli forces who have been conducted
in conducting nearly nightly braids on
Palestinian towns here in the occupied
West Bank thank you very much indeed
clearly we're in the early hours of this
story as we're finding out more we're
going to be coming back to you but for
now Anita Ibrahim from Bethlehem thank
you very much indeed